[Musique]
bon me voici arrivé au festival
d'angoulem et non B don dans spectateur
je sais ce que tu es en train de te dire
mais il ne s'agit pas du festival de
bande dessiné qui fait le bonheur de
l'Office de Tourisme plutôt dans l'année
non là il s'agit du Festival du film
francophone qui en est aujourd'hui à sa
7e édition créé en 2008 sous l'impulsion
des producteurs marifrance Brière
Patrick mardquan et Dominique besneard
le festival met l'accent comme son nom
l'indique sur le cinéma francophone et a
connu en quelques années une croissance
assez fulgurante qui en fait aujourd'hui
un événement au moins aussi courtisé
qu'une afterur de réine chez M CUS
oui cette année le jury est présidé par
Sabine Ker de feu Azema et comporte des
personnalités au profil très divers
depuis le musicien Abdel Malik jusqu'à
l'humoriste Stéphane de Groot en passant
par l'actrice AA maigair un en arrière
vivre un festival est toujours une
expérience particulière comme
l'événement doit s'adresser à tous mais
aussi rester pointu sur cette thématique
ses choix de programmation deviennent
forcément tout fu et cornélien et dans
ce contexte le spectateur se retrouve
face à un dilemme puisque tout faire et
tout voir relève de l'impossible et la
borison planning ressemble rapidement à
une partie de roulettees
russe aujourd'hui un flexible internaute
je vous propose donc un petit journal de
bord de mes déambulation au sein du
festival d'angoulem un journal de bord
forcément personnel et non exhaustif
mais je l'espère représentatif de la
température de
l'événement l'accréditation est
récupérée la porte d'entrée de l'hôtel
franchiss sans vterer il est maintenant
temps d'attaquer la cérémonie
d'ouverture après laquelle sera présenté
tu veux ou tu veux pas une comédie de
Tony Marchall sur l'addiction au sexe
qui propose une splendide main au cul
sur son affiche hop ce qui n'est pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rien très joli hier soir il y avait une
vraie
attente on sentait depuis quelques
quelques semaines qu' qu' avait même
depuis début du tournage depuis les
premières photos qu'on avait posté sur
Facebook ou sur Twitter qui avait
quelque chose de d'assez d'assez
agréable et cétait très attendu par les
gens que ce ce ce couple visiblement
plaît mais on s'attendait pas à un
accueil pareil hier
soir on est toujours très heureux quand
on voit des salles pleines de cinéma
c'est quand même pour nous un peu la
récompense de voilà de travail et puis
d'une
relation nous ça nous arrive quand on
est au théâtre mais enf sinon on est
toujours un peu loin du public et voilà
et de de les voir nous regarder comme ça
c'est un peu émouvant toujours la
particularité du festival d'angoulem est
qu'il a su prendre de l'importance tout
en conservant une taille relativement
modeste ce qui lui permet une proximité
généralement appréciée avec le public
l'événement se décrit lui-même comme un
festival où les vedettes ne jouent pas
au vedettes ce qui n'empêche pas le
public de les traiter comme tel quoi
qu'il arrive c'est bien là le paradoxe
du star
système disons plutôt que grâce à une
logistique réduite les personnalités on
présence peuvent en toute logique se
laisser aller à plus de
simplicité deux des têes d'affiches de
l'événement CAD m et Olivier B qui n'ont
pas souhaité garder l'anonymma et qui
rendent donc la pudeur de mon approche
complètement inutile sont venus
présenter leur nouveau film on a marché
sur Bangkok un petit
sourire sour on fait que ça les deux
larons vvrant sur le créneau comédie
populaire j'imagine que face à l'effet
proximité d'angoulem ils ne doivent pas
avoir à trop se forcer non on se force
pas d'autant plus que lorsqu'on vient
par exemple ici on sait exactement
pourquoi on est là voilà on n'est pas
agressé on a pas on a aucune raison de
d'écarter les gens enfin je veux dire
c'est c'est c'est notre public c'est le
public qui va voir les films qui nous
permet d'en faire d'autres enfin c'est
un minimum que de respecter les
spectateurs et d'écouter ce qu'ils ont à
dire et de leur faire plaisir en pendant
des photos enens les autographes
vraiment faut changer de métier va quand
on vient présenter avec Olivier et
surtout avec Olivier où ça fait quand
même plusieurs années qu'on qu'on se
présente des films et qu'on bah écoute
on a toujours la même je pense la même
la même timidité la même envie de de
parler aux gens moi j'aime bien on voit
des gamins on voit des voilà c'est c'est
c'est pas du respect oui c'est aussi du
respect du public je pense parce que
c'est quand même le public qui va faire
le succès du
film bon le festival àêtre de taille
modeste ça n'empêche pas que face à son
succès de fréquentation il faut s'armer
de patience ou d'une machette rouillée
ou des deux mais là je demande d'avoir
la gueule du combo bref o on étaisje ah
oui être un festival agréable à vivre
c'est une chose arriver à être pertinent
dans le paysage et le cinéma français
CEN est une autre des festivals il y en
a une tripoté et dans ce foisonnement il
est facile de devenir superflu qu'est-ce
qui différencie donc celui d'angoulè des
autres personnellement je n'en sais
strictement rien étant donné que je
viens d'arriver mais l'acteur Raphaël
Personna qui n'en est pas à sa première
participation et présente cette année
SK1 la trraque de Guig George pourrait
avoir une hypothèse maintenant tous les
films veulent veulent être à angoulem
parce c'est un petit peu j'ai
l'impression le baromètre de de du du
début de l'année scolaire quoi pour les
pour les pour les pour les films et que
ouais c'est et puis la rencontre compte
mine de rien des professionnels et du
public ça donne une tendance assez assez
nette de de ce que va être la la vie
d'un film l'année dernière il y avait eu
doré ça avait été très bien reçu il y
avait eu le Dupontel aussi ici qui était
venu qui avait qui avait tout de suite
fait parler de lui quoi donc on sent
très vite quel film va va marquer à un
moment donné le le public sans trop se
tromper un peu avant je parlait du côté
quasi indéboulonnable du star système et
forcément quel que soit la taille de
l'événement ou l'image de simplicité
qu'il peut avoir la chasse aux
autographes fait partie du jeu véritable
sport homologué dont les champions
développent des trésors d'imagination
qui feraiit passer un escadron de moine
chaoline pour une bande d'arthritique
grippée toutefois enfonçant guardement
les portes ouvertes l'admiration
n'est-elle pas avant tout un sentiment
universel ça tombe bien l'équipe d'ador
semble avoir étudié la question puisque
le film met en scène une fan qui va
jusqu'à cacher un cadavre pour son idole
Sandrine kiberlin et Laurent laffit ont
le même un tempérament de fan révélation
fracassante ou pas moi j'ai pas un
tempérament de fan non il a des gens qui
admiré mais je continue à admirer mais
non j'aurais jamais caché un corps pour
même pour Laurent la
fit un festival est une entité assez
unique par-delà les œuvres présentées on
a affaire à un espace-temps très
immersif régi par des codes qui pousse
le brave festivalier à s'extraire de son
quotidien ce qui n'empêche pas parfois
le quotidien en question de le rattraper
assez
abruptement bordel je le sentait mal ce
resto bon le temps de trouver une
solution je vous laisse avec les images
d'Hippocrate nouvelle étape dans la
quête de Vincent Lacoste pour casser
l'image d'ado nux qui le colle à la peau
depuis les beau goss voilà c'est
parfait apothicaire
apotiicaire là tuas l'accueil derrière
c'est le bureau des internes c'est chez
toi 10 chambres 18 pass 18 c'est la
première fois que je que je joue un
personnage qui a un
métier d'ailleurs qui a un métier c'est
la premre fois que je joue un personnage
qui a un métier ah ou ou donc voilà vous
buviez combien par jour dans les 40
40 et comment on fait pour boire 40
bières par jour tout en travaillant je
tiens un bar oui pause technique si
l'événement est immersif il faut aussi
savoir prendre du recul pour se
réorganiser au mieux car au milieu des
trousaines de milliers d'activités
festivalières il faut rester vigilant
les bonnes et mauvaises expériences se
chevauchent laissant dans leur sillage
un calédoscope de souvenir divers et
varié et magie de la transition
complètement fortuite Jean-Paul rou va
justement réalisé un film du même nom
parmi ces acteurs principaux on retrouve
Michel Blanc aussi connu sous le
sonbrquier de Michael white dans le
milieu autorisé et le monsieur a
souhaité s'exprimer sur son meilleur
souvenir de festival au sens large ce
qui tombe plutôt bien ça va peut-être me
changer les
idées le meilleur c'est forcément can
parce que bon d'abord can c'est assez
magique he d'une certaine manière on est
on se dit même simplement d'être en
sélection même si on a rien il y a c'est
c'est c'est un truc très fort d'avoir
été choisi déjà en sélection puis alors
en plus quand vous avez avait un prix
bon moi j'en ai eu deux j'ai eu le prix
du de de d'interprétation pour tenue de
soirée et puis prix du scénario pour une
comédieque alors déjà être sélectionné à
CAN avec grosse fatigue avec une comédie
moi ça m'a bluffé et puis alors après
quand on m'a dit que j'avais le prix du
scénario non c'est classe mais c'est pas
l'album que je cherche si angoulem ne se
limite pas à son festival de bande
dessiné chassez le naturel et il revient
au Galot bien vénère et sous stéroïde à
ce titre le film lou journal infime a
doublement sa place au festival étant
donné qu'il est adapté de la BD du même
nom les tiers croisés de cohérence si
que ça de vrait K cojandi qui fait
partie de la distribution est sur place
comme beaucoup d'autres pour se prêter
aux jeux des interviews vu le planning
serré ça tient plutôt du marathon mais
aujourd'hui K et Jas à la fraîche il
sent sur le courant du cosmos donc quoi
de mieux que de l'emmerder pendant ses
pauses mais je suis heureux là regarde
qu'est-ce que tu veux de plus mer du
soleil attention intervention garantie
sans clin d'œil ultra prévisible bref
non mais merde les gars là non mais faut
faut m'écouter là est-ce que je peux
mettre mes l de soleil ça vous dérange
pas pour la photo non pour après et tu
sais que à ce stade tu peux acheter un
iPad
heô
attention tuas pas envie d'éternuer
quand tu es face au soleil comme ça
c'est un mec avec une caméra qui suit
c'est mon cousin voilà il savent pas
trop quoi faire ils sont gentils les
gens il sont assez bienveillant ils ont
vu le film il l'aiment beaucoup
donc c'est marrant c'est que tu changes
de ton avec les journalistes tu es là tu
es là tu fais oui absolument c'est vrai
que c'est très important de oui pu vous
savez j'ai une anecdote làdessus pu tu
es
très dans la vie FO en tant qu'acteur tu
commences à parler un peu comme ça fais
gaffe il un reportage sur toi je crois
oh
merde dernière interview merci beaucoup
je quelque chose c'est sûr c'est gentil
merci
beaucoup j'espère que le film va vous
plaire en tout parce que on a mis tout
notre cœur et et il y a que de la
sincérité là-dedans salut on a beau se
trouver dans un festival du Film
Francophone ça n'empêche bien entendu
pas l'ouverture à l'internationale
aujourd'hui dans un contexte de
mondialisation bienvelue les frontières
sont plus poreuses que jamais ce qui qui
rend autant les sources de financement
que les équipes de production de plus en
plus
diversifié sur cette édition Jemma bovry
en est un bon exemple avec sa
réactualisation du roman de Flobert qui
confronte Fabrice Lucini et la
sublimement mutine Jemma Arterton allez
sautons joyeusement à l'étape du j'adore
la France et donnons sans retenu dans le
cliché qui fait plaisir en demandant à
Jemma quelles sont selon elle les bonnes
raisons de vivre
[Musique]
ici la culture il y a une bonne une
vraie appréciation pour ça et et moi
j'habite à Londres on a un grand culture
mais en fait c'est c'est très supporté
en
[Musique]
France je je elle dit quoi j'arrive pas
à me concentrer
là bon le festival touche à sa fin il
est donc temps de saluer l'expérience
avant de disparaître dans un nuage de
fumée et quitte à se donner bonne
conscience tapons allègrement dans
l'excuse étymologique en invoquant la
racine festif du festival en plus le
timing a l'air de faire des merveilles
puisque breev de comptoir de Jean-Michel
RIB est l'un des derniers films
programmés alors on traqué quoi au
succès ah bah oui au succès et à
l'avenir au brve de comptoir et à
angoulis mais au festival quand même oui
c'était concis bref admirable spectateur
il ne me reste plus qu'à m'éclipser à
l'aide d'une sortie de chant classique
mais efficace le bisou
festivalier